Joe Biden ended Bernie Sanders his
campaign last night with massive
victories in Missouri Mississippi and
Michigan we will examine how Bernie fell
apart and what troubles remain ahead for
sleepy Joe then eat the rich YouTube
socialist Carlos masa gets exposed as a
rich guy revealing a key generational
difference between old left socialists
like Sanders and millennial socialists
like maza all that and so much more I'm
Michel Knowles and this is the Michael
Noel's show
[Music]
poor Bernie Sanders never thought I
would say that but the guy got blown out
of the water last night so last night we
had little Super Tuesday or Super
Tuesday 2.0 we had the real Super
Tuesday last week was the last week or
two weeks ago everything is like
blurring together now this campaign has
changed so quickly you know if you'd
asked me to three weeks ago who's gonna
be the nominee of the Democratic Party
just looking at the numbers you'd have
to say Bernie Sanders now the guy got
blown out of the water last night we
heard from voters in Washington Missouri
Mississippi Idaho North Dakota and
Michigan how did they do Bernie didn't
get completely blown out I mean he
didn't it's not like he lost every
single state he won Michigan or he won
rather Washington he won North Dakota
but the big states of the night all went
to Joe Biden Biden got Missouri that's
worth sixty eight delegates they're
gonna have proportional delegates but
just to give you a sense of the size of
these states Missouri Mississippi were
thirty six delegates and then the big
prize of the night
Michigan worth 125 delegates went to Joe
Biden so for all intents and purposes
Bernie Sanders is out of the race
his campaign has said that they're not
going to concede right away will maybe
take a look at why that is but already
President Trump is turning all of his
attention to Joe Biden the Trump
campaign released a video last night
just immediately dunking on sleepy Joe
and implying that he's too senile to
become President Obama warned Biden's
aides to make sure Biden didn't
embarrass himself my name is Joe Biden
I'm a Democratic candidate
State Senate we hold these truths to be
self-evident all men are created by the
goal you know this you know the thing a
hundred and fifty million people have
been killed since 2007 when Bernie voted
to exempt the gun manufacturers three
granddaughters are down in Dubuque with
my wife Jill and so in Des Moines I said
something dumb in Dubuque
all right Jeff thank you very much all
right
it's Christmas play the radio make sure
the television the excuse me make sure
you have the record player on it night
text Joe two three I gotta get this
right
[Music]
the line dog-faced Pony said I let it be
clear I'm not going nothing is that
clear I don't think that's clear it's
really awful when you watch all of that
together and just consider for a moment
that of all the 320 million Americans
this is the best the Democrats could
pick you know how big was that field 27
people at one point and the actual best
candidate that they could field is that
guy I said yesterday on the show that we
need to have a new segment which is
called what jumbled nonsense came out of
Joe Biden's mouth today because every
day there's more and every day we got to
cover it well guess what yesterday
didn't disappoint Joe Biden was in
Detroit he was talking to some auto
workers there and one of them challenged
him on his anti second amendment
policies and the Joe Biden now the
presumptive Democratic nominee told the
guy he was full of Sh I T threatened to
take him outside and then started
rambling on about the mythical AR 14
assault rifle
[Applause]
hold on let's let's pause it right there
for a second he goes on but imagine just
for a moment if President Trump or if
any other Republican politician ever
shush
a female campaign aide on camera is
that's what's happening this guy is
talking to Joe Biden he says hey you've
got some pretty anti Second Amendment
policies guys you're full of Sh I D and
then the female eye goes okay we're done
here let's see it she goes no shush
shush Dollface hey come on your pony
soldier wouldn't wouldn't go over very
well then Joe Biden gets to the meat of
what he's saying and it it doesn't go
terribly well we'll get to that in a
second first I want to thank our friends
over at zip recruiter according to the
US Bureau of Labor Statistics Hawaii is
the state experiencing the highest wage
growth man that states got everything
going for it but while higher wages
attract more and better candidates
competition for talent remains intense
so if you need to find the best
candidates for your growing business zip
recruiter is your smart efficient hiring
solution from healthcare to
manufacturing to professional and
business services zip recruiter makes
hiring great people faster and easier
and today you can try sip recruiter for
free at zip recruiter comm slash Knowles
do it right now I'm telling you it's not
like throwing spaghetti at the wall it
goes out and invites the best people to
apply you've got to use it it will save
you time and money in hiring tricep
recruiter for free at zip recruiter comm
slash Knowles canna wles that zip
recruiter comm /ko wles
zip recruiter comm slash Knowles the
smartest way to hire ok so he shushes
the the female campaign aid now it's
worth pointing out Joe Biden has a
pretty bad record on the Second
Amendment he has said that he's going to
take away people's guns
Eirias
[Music]
that's not free speech
so he's denying it right now I never
said I would take your guns away I never
said I would take your guns away roll
the tape to gun owners out there who say
well a bind Administration means they're
gonna come for my guns bingo you're
right if you have an assault weapon
bingo bingo bango look at that so he he
does this all the time Joe Biden maybe
it's because he genuinely doesn't
remember having said these things but
he'll just actually it's been going on
so long in his career I think it's just
a feature not a bug of his character he
can lie effortlessly so he can just look
you in the face and say I never said I
would take away your guns I never said
that look and the auto worker he's
saying I saw it on tape I saw you saying
goes yeah there's a lot of tape it's all
selectively edited it's all manipulate
don't believe what you see on TV kid
well look we can look at the interview
of Joe Biden talking to Anderson Cooper
he says bingo I'm going to take away
your guns and then Joe Biden really to
put the cherry on top of the sundae gets
to the heart of our gun problem it's the
scourge of the mythical AR 14
[Applause]
guys
there's a lot of
this is so embarrassing for Joe Biden
some of Joe Biden's defenders are trying
to spin this as yeah he stood up to this
guy first of all no he didn't he
eventually just walked away the guy was
perfectly polite and Joe Biden threatens
to take him outside by the way I really
hope for Joe's sake that no one ever
takes him up on this offer how many
times does Joe Biden said I'll challenge
you to push-ups you want to go take this
outside I'll punch you you want to Joe
Biden is a 77 year old man who can't
remember his own name if if he actually
goes outside with somebody not going to
end very well for him then he obviously
just walks away
so he's standing up to these people and
saying well I'm just gonna take away
your ar-15s
air a r14 rather a or 14 not the gun
he's talking about AR 14 product of
Joe's imagination ar-15 is the actual
gun but he's wrong about the ar-15 he
says to the guy you shouldn't be able to
have an ar-15 guy says why not he says
well because it's a what are you allowed
to have a machine gun the guy very
reasonably says ar-15s are not machine
guns they're just semi-automatic rifles
like every other rifle you pull the
trigger once one round comes out because
yeah yeah you're gonna you can't hear
you I had to have a hundred rounds said
well look around most states here you
can't can't even have a hundred round
magazine this is pathetic for a few
reasons one is Joe bide the slipping but
there are a lot of anti-gun politicians
who would have given this exact same
answer and that's really pathetic this
this Detroit auto worker his job is not
to regulate gun policy his job is not to
know about this issue and yet he does
because it would appear he's a
responsible citizen Joe Biden's job for
50 years was to deal in these issues of
policy and he knows nothing about it
he's made guns a big big plank of his
campaign he doesn't know anything about
them he doesn't know what the name of
the gun is he doesn't know what the type
of the gun is he doesn't know what the
gun does he doesn't know anything about
it and I'm not even going after him on a
political or ideological level I'm going
after him on a base knowledge level he's
simply ignorant of the thing that
he is not only talking about but trying
to regulate very embarrassing
interaction and he just looks like an
angry angry old man I mean the first
thing I thought of when he when he used
a r14 was not even the gun angle it was
the losing his marbles angle it's like
if somebody who's very very old says you
kids and your Gameboy computers and your
your doo-wop cassette records and you're
in it's like they're just using terms
that don't really make sense together
that's what Joe Biden was doing because
he's really checked out and yet this guy
who is half comatose barely knows where
he is is running away with the
nomination so what other people in the
Democratic Party want when they see
videos like this is they want to cancel
the rest of the primary this is not my
conspiracy theory major Democrats are
now publicly voicing this opinion so Jim
Clyburn a democratic representative from
South Carolina he said yesterday I think
when the night is over Joe Biden will be
the prohibitive favorite to win the
Democratic nomination quite frankly if
the night ends the way it's begun I
think it is time for us to shut down
this primary I think it is time for us
to cancel the rest of the debates
because you don't do anything but get
yourself in trouble if you continue in
this contest when it's obvious that the
numbers will not shake out for you and
then he went on to reiterate this he
said Biden will get himself into trouble
and will say something that he quote
cannot overcome if this goes on so you
got a you got to end it now not just Jim
Clyburn legendary democratic political
consultant James Carville said pretty
much the exact same thing
mission as a party is to defeat Donald
Trump according to 538 there's a 99 or 1
chance that that Vice President Biden is
gonna be the nominee let's shut this
puppy down and let's move on and worry
about November this thing is decided
there's no reason to keep it going it
but not even a day longer in many ways
they're both right they're right that
Joe Biden's gonna get himself into
trouble that he's pretty much locked up
the nomination that there's no reason in
terms of the selection process to keep
this thing going however they're wrong
in that you don't win by not campaigning
okay if you are so terrified that your
presumptive nominee is gonna say
something stupid that you you think
you're gonna win by locking him away for
six months you don't have a great
candidate you you cannot win in politics
by not doing something or by avoiding
that's exactly what they want to do and
it's not just them there are a number of
very prominent Democrats who are not
ready fully to endorse Joe Biden you
know we heard yesterday from Nancy
Pelosi and Hillary Clinton but there are
others too and they're making exactly
the same point by the way I want to
remind you that if you want to ask any
questions from you know if you're
listening on The Daily wire chat box the
app the website send them in and we'll
try to get to something from a Michael
what would you say to the Liberals who
are likely accusing us of making a
medical diagnosis of Joe Biden's mental
state without having met him or having a
proper medical training there is a
difference here so we're not making a
medical diagnosis I'm not saying Joe
Biden has Alzheimer's disease Joe Biden
has Parkinson's disease Joe but I'm not
actually making a medical diagnosis in
the way that the left does with Donald
Trump they do this with Donald Trump all
the time they say he's a sociopath he's
is a narcissist
he's they accuse him of having incest
fantasies I mean they accuse him of all
sorts of really creepy and specific
psychological problems but we're
accusing Joe Biden of having is old age
all right you don't need a medical
degree to accuse somebody of being old
because the evidence is right there for
you the evidence is he's forgetting
everybody's name he is saying things
that don't make any sense he's garbling
his sentences I you know I always say
pull back on the psychobabble do not
start diagnosing people out of the DSM
if you're sitting watching a TV even if
you are a medical doctor but if you've
ever been around somebody who's over the
at the age that Joe is currently at you
don't need a medical degree to point out
that someone is
long in the tooth Maxine Waters right
now major major Democrat in Congress she
too is not ready to settle on Biden
I'm just asking members about the
primary big primaries tonight are you
backing Biden or Bernie I have not
endorsed anybody who do you like most
it's compared to the vine and Bernie
compared it's not about who you like
it's about now watching and
understanding who can beat Trump do you
think Biden has what it takes to be
Trump I don't know but we'll see I don't
know but we'll see you know Maxine
Waters occasionally says something
honest and that's right I if I were a
Democrat I would not be sure the Biden
has what it takes to beat Trump and
really even the people defending him
like James Carville saying he's got this
wrapped up let's go and put this away
now let's get it another puppy back in
the shed now even those guys are saying
it because they're not certain that Joe
Biden has what it takes we'll get to
this all in just a second but first got
to thank our friends over a rock Auto my
car broke down a little while ago
I don't know anything about cars right
so I go to the auto parts shop the auto
parts shop they don't ever have the part
so they go online they go and order
online then they charge me a lot of
extra money and I still don't even know
what I'm looking at well guess what if
you have a computer you have the
Internet and if you have the Internet
that means you have access to
rockauto.com at home and in your pocket
rockauto.com always offers the lowest
price as possible rather than changing
prices based on what the market will
bear like you know airlines do that
right but Rock Auto always has the most
reliable prices why spend up to twice as
much for the same parts here's a random
example right the Delft EFG 1456 fuel
pump assembly for 2005 to 2010 honda
odyssey is 350 $3.99 at advanced big
chain store right and it is 216 79 at
rockauto.com that's the way these guys
always are go to rockauto.com right now
check out all the parts available for
your car or truck right Knowles in there
how did you hear about us box and they
will know that we sent you and not just
Maxine Waters Jill Stein you remember
her she was the Green Party politician
last time she's run a number of times
Jill Stein is is tweeting out quote
Biden's lies and record or bad enough
but the biggest risk is his obvious
cognitive decline
he said he's running for Senate confused
wife and sister forgot Obama's name etc
this isn't going away if Dems close
their eyes and keep pushing Joe it'll be
an agonizing eight months ahead and then
the PSI I agree with her I never thought
I'd agree with Jill Stein the pas de
resistance is bill de blasio the
Bolshevik mayor of New York who points
out that Joe Biden has not been vetted
this time around and I tell you
something else our candidate needs to be
vetted Joe I am deeply concerned
Bernie started to get vetted quite a bit
and that's important for running Rea for
the general election Joe Biden hasn't
been vetted he was in a perfect position
early frontrunner then everyone thought
he wasn't going to make it turn their
attention to Bloomberg Bernie
even if Warren for awhile Joe Biden has
a lot of issues he needs to speak to if
we don't deal with it now in the family
and have that blunt discussion this
Donald Trump will so morning Joe over
here is starts laughing when Bill de
Blasio says this because basically Joe
Biden has been in politics every day for
50 years what do you mean he hasn't been
vetted he's been vetted as much as
anybody
he's now run for president three times
he was the vice president what are you
talking about he hasn't been vetted
circumstances change this is not the Joe
Biden of 1974 okay this is a very
different Joe Biden and he has not been
vetted first of all even if you just
look at his positions his positions have
changed so in the purely ideological
level we really don't know who this guy
is because doesn't believe in very much
so he's willing to say a whole lot of
things for instance for his whole career
he defended the Hyde Amendment which
theoretically protected taxpayers from
paying for abortions now he's ready to
let taxpayers pay for abortions just one
easy example also there's the cognitive
decline aspect Joe Biden didn't use to
forget people's names and forget where
he was and then there
the corruption aspect that's the third
one that to me is is probably going to
be more important in the long run so
obviously there gonna be a lot of
attacks from actually some people on the
left probably too but obviously from
President Trump on how Joe Biden is
losing his marbles that's why he called
him sleepy Joe early on in the campaign
you remember the big attack on Biden was
that he was giving people shoulder
massages and they were trying to meat to
him basically and Donald Trump didn't go
for that if Trump had gone for that he
would have called him creepy Joe creepy
Joe with the shoulder massages smelling
the hair you didn't go for creepy Joe he
went for a rhyme which was sleepy G
sleepy Joe because if you see him for
any period of time you realize Joe Biden
is not as energetic as he wants what is
his mind is not moving as quickly so a
lot of attacks for that
however there there will also be a tax
on Joe Biden's corruption and this is
something that very few people have
talked about at length and Joe Biden's
career it's only really come up recently
with some of the hunter Biden
revelations but it's a weird thing it's
a weird thing that during Joe Biden's 50
years in government for some reason
coincidentally everybody with the last
name Biden has gotten a lot richer now
weird you're not supposed to make a
whole lot of money in politics and
you're definitely not supposed to make
money just because your family is in
politics right why on earth would
someone pay you money for that and yet
over Joe Biden's half-century at the top
of our politics his family has gotten
really really rich and it's not just
hunter Biden everyone knows about hunter
Biden don't forget about Joe's brother
James Biden James Biden has a long trail
of corruption so just one quick example
recently James Biden used his political
ties to convince the executives at
AmeriCorps health which is a health care
firm out in the country to loan him
$650,000 why why would he get that loan
he convinced them to give him that loan
because he said that he would be able to
secure larger investments from Middle
Eastern contacts thanks to the Biden
name so he was getting into health care
investing and he told these partners
like AmeriCorps that Joe Biden
now James James is the guy asking for
the money that his brother Joe was very
excited about the public policy
implications of this new venture and you
know really they could probably use that
by name to get some money out of the
Middle East
that's according to Politico Politico
released that just two days ago now I'm
not even saying Joe Biden was
necessarily complicit in this though
you'd think if this if this pattern goes
on long enough you might have told his
brother stop trading my name for money
stop doing this but it's gone on longer
it wasn't just a one-time event there's
there's a track record here and then of
course it goes 200 Biden we'll get to
that in a second first I want to thank
our friends over at paint your life if
you want to give a truly meaningful gift
you've got to try paint your life calm I
love this thing I think it is like one
of the coolest services available today
you can have an original painting of
yourself or your children your family or
a dog or a special place you can have it
done oil painting or other kinds of
paintings too at a price you can afford
from paint your life calm he does a true
painting done by hand by a world-class
artist created from a favorite photo I
just love this thing I did not trust
that it would be high quality when I saw
it so I wanted to try it out first and I
didn't try it on me I tried it on my
step-brother for his wedding I had this
gaurab solutely gorgeous painting made
for a price that would shock you I don't
really understand how the business model
works because the quality is so so good
do it you are not gonna regret this and
by the way let's not forget
conservatives really should support like
the aesthetic realm of the world you
know we should care about beauty a lot
no better way than to have an original
painting done for your home for not too
much money right now for a limited time
you get 30% off your painting 30% off
and free shipping to get this offer text
the word Michael 264 thousand that's
mi CH AE L to 64,000 Michael 64,000 so
it's not just the loan that he got
trading on his brother's name james
Biden during the Obama administration
received over one and a half billion
dollars in government backed contracts
while his brother was vice president now
we're seeing a real pattern right
because the hunter Biden corruption
happened well Joe was vice president too
in 2010 James Biden joined Hill Stone
international as executive vice
president this is a firm working on
construction and tech projects
particularly overseas say why is James
Biden joining as the executive vice
president of that firm James Biden's not
like swinging a hammer he's not some
well-known construction genius no he had
no experience but he did have the last
name Biden and this helped him get
contracts in Iraq to the tune of one and
a half billion dollars pretty clear
corruption to me then you get to hunter
the update on hunter Biden right now by
the way in case you haven't been paying
attention to the tabloids
he is currently living in a very very
expensive house in Hollywood Hills right
here where I live
he's I don't live in as ritzy a
neighborhood as hunter Biden is of
course because my last name is now Biden
he's got a Porsche sitting in the garage
and he's just painting all day he
converted a pool house into an art
studio and while he's doing that he's
refusing to show up to court hearings
for child support payments on the child
that he sired out of wedlock with a
stripper while he was cheating on his
late brother's widow and this was after
he left his first wife that's just the
personal scandal that one actually
doesn't even matter that much the only
reason I bring it up is the left has
made it so personal now in the thrum p--
administration so the left is started
going off after Trump's kids remember
during the whole Russia gate hoax they
were trying to throw Don jr. in jail
they're constantly attacking the Trump
family that from children and they're
accusing Trump of having incestuous
desires I mean they're really sick stuff
right
so the
the only reason I say that is because it
means that hunter on a personal level is
going to be an issue on this campaign
what's good for the goose is good for
the gander the bigger scandal is the
corruption
so hunter Biden paid much much more
money to sit on the board of a corrupt
Ukrainian energy company than he would
have been paid on the board of exxon
mobil hunter biden has no expertise in
ukraine or in energy he's got a lot of
expertise and sitting on boards because
those are the corrupt jobs that he's
gotten by virtue of his last name that's
going to be a big issue how is Joe gonna
answer that not quite sure and then the
question is what happens to Bernie we'll
get to that in a second first let's take
a question from BB hey Knowles
I really can't seem to figure out why
the DNC chose to sideline Tulsi she may
not be the best friend of the
establishment but she is clearly the
best candidate what do you think no I
don't think she's the best candidate
first of all I think that her views are
to heterodox that's why she's making
some common cause with people on the
right I mean she checks the boxes
superficially that the left wants right
they say they want a woman they say they
want an ethnic minority they say they
want a young person she'll said Tulsi
Gabbard checks all of those boxes but
you know they don't usually end up going
that way right they've been the
Democrats have been saying that for so
long they really want minorities and
women and yeah okay their nominating Joe
Biden it looks like this time last time
they nominated a white woman so at least
she was a woman by their account but you
know she's still white then before that
yeah I guess they had Barack Obama then
they had John Kerry just a boring old
white guy then they had Al Gore he's
just a boring old white guy and they had
Bill Clinton at the time he was a boring
slightly younger white guy and part of
his part of his presidency wasn't that
boring but you see my point they talk a
much better game on this kind of
intersectional issue than they actually
play and tulsi gabbard would not
maintain the liberal establishment so
that's their big issue with her
particularly on foreign policy she's too
much of an independent thinker and what
the Democrats and what the left want to
do most urgently is to defend that
liberalist
she won't do it so she's people are not
gonna say her name she's the candidate
who must not be named and soon that's
gonna happen to Bernie Sanders too so
what happens to him now Bernie Sanders
predicted that he would win in Michigan
but he said that he wouldn't drop out
either way he told Chris Wallace just
the other day said I certainly would not
consider dropping out we're also seeing
now that his campaign is saying he's not
going to drop out immediately Bernie
Sanders is doubling down now on his
praise of Fidel Castro he's going to go
out on his shield okay Bernie Sanders is
is not going to go out with a whimper
he's going to go out with a bang here's
Bernie just recently doubling down on
Castro there are a few moments in races
that seem like turning points and many
experts looked at that moment on 60
minutes when you talked about Fidel
Castro's literary literacy program as a
turning point in this race do you agree
at all saying what you said at that time
in this race no look I have spent my
entire life fighting for working people
and fighting for democracy no I don't
regret it
I mean what he has just said I've fought
for working people in democracy is just
clearly untrue he's defending in the
same breath Fidel Castro okay who has
been nothing but a devil and a plague
for the working people of Cuba and who
certainly is not a Democrat lowercase D
he honeymooned in the Soviet Union not
great for working people certainly not a
democracy
he's a defended the worst regimes on
earth but the reason I point this out is
Bernie Sanders is not gonna try to
moderate a little bit to win the
nomination he sees the writing on the
wall and he is going to go down swinging
so it's the end of the road in many ways
that frankly I wouldn't be surprised if
he ran again in four years but if he
were to run again in four years it would
be like a Mike Ravel kind of candidacy
Mike Ravel was that very very old left
winger who kind of nominally ran this
time just to get his ideas out there but
not in any way making a serious play
certainly not like he did in 2020 this
is it this is the end of the road for
Bernie
he's he's not gonna compromise on what
he wants not gonna compromise on his
values especially now Bernie is so much
better in opposition right Bernie is not
really good when he's the front-runner
he doesn't know to play the front-runner
he's not very good when he's in power he
doesn't actually accomplish anything
when he's in the Senate but he's really
good from the outside he's really good
at attacking the establishment that's
where he's been most effective and so I
think if anything you're gonna see a
little fresh boost of energy into the
campaign now that it's completely lost
we've got to get to another generation
of socialists another generation of
leftist hypocrisy in the form of Carlos
Massa because Carlos Massa that YouTube
guy who tries to get all the
Conservatives kicked off the internet
carlos has a little secret
we'll get to that in a second first I've
got to thank our friends over at blinks
ale you know being your own boss is
great but running your own business is
not always easy
whether you have employees or not
there's billing there's accounting or
staying organized and no matter how boss
you are no one's great at it all of the
time that's where blink sale comes in
blink sale makes it easy to send
professional invoices and track payments
in just a few seconds you can create
invoices send them to clients and keep
up with them until they get paid forget
about using invoice templates or
stressing about coordinating a bunch of
different software programs blink sale
takes care of it all that's less time
worrying about billing and what that
means is more time focusing on the work
that actually gets you paid I really
love these guys it's so simple it makes
it makes it also much easier to deal I'm
not a organized guy I would much rather
be either doing the work I want to do or
like sitting back somewhere smoking a
stogie this takes that all that awful
organizing work out of your hands and
makes it so simple see for yourself
try blink sale for free right now blink
sale calm that's a BL I NK s al e comm
blink sale spend less time billing and
more time doing what you love right now
we're giving 25% off daily wire plans
when you use the coupon code never
socialist head on over there because it
looks like that poor socialist in the
race is on his way out
never socialists go to Daley
dot-com / subscribe we'll be right back
with a lot more
as one socialist leaves the political
world another socialist intercept so
Bernie Sanders is on his way out
Carlos Massa is picking up the mantle
for the working man this guy is not just
I want to sort of raise your taxes rich
people socialist he is a full-on
overthrow capitalism and eat the rich
socialist here he is in case you
forgotten
the long dark night of the end of
history has to be grasped as an enormous
opportunity the very oppressive
pervasiveness of capitalist realism
means that even glimmers of alternative
political and economic realities can
have a disproportionately great effect
the tiniest events can tear a hole in
the gray curtain of reaction which has
marked the horizon of possibility from a
situation in which nothing can happen
suddenly anything is possible
Wow okay and if you were just listening
to that if you couldn't see that Carlos
Maz is there wearing a wife-beater tank
top and holding like a sledgehammer over
his shoulder like he's got a bandana
around his neck like workers of the
world unite now it's very hard for me to
take seriously the idea that someone who
talks for a living
is like out there in the field you know
the proletariat socialist hacks for all
of human history have tried to give that
impression and they never do it terribly
credibly but Carlos Moses certainly
plays the part right he puts on the
costume and he says all the lines he
says he hates the rich and he hates
capitalism
you're just here just a few tweets from
masa just found out James Carville who
spends his time lecturing Democrats for
being too far left lives in an
absolutely obscene four-story mansion
dear God can we stop taking political
advice from the ultra-wealthy
you really have to respect this guy's
grift constantly dressing in normal
clothes on TV to feign relatability
while living like this
masterful con artists pay attention to
that let's go come back in a little bit
he is attack
James Carville for wearing silly
proletariat clothing well actually he's
very rich and he's saying that's
hypocritical okay just just wait for it
for a moment he's got other tweets he
says we should treat gay people the same
way we treat straight people eating them
when they get too rich I got to eat the
rich got it so it turns out here's the
punchline
are you ready could you expect it Carlos
maza is very rich I know you couldn't
couldn't have seen that one coming
Carlos Maz is not just like like his
grandpa left him a nice inheritance rich
okay Carlos masa is not just like the
stocks are doing well this year at rich
Carlos masa didn't just win you know a
scratcher ticket and got like five grand
or something Carlos masa is super duper
rich he's connected to multiple giant
mansions in Florida he's connected to a
7 point 1 million dollar apartment on
the Upper West Side which is purchased
under an LLC which is a thing rich
people do they buy apartments under
company names for privacy and tax
benefits and he's connected to a yacht
made by the luxury boat maker
Dunsey public records show that his
mother Vivian and his family a
stepfather they're registered to vote at
a 5 bedroom
8 bathroom waterfront palace in Boca
Raton Florida the property sold a couple
years ago for ten point eight million
dollars also it turns out that that he's
connected to a four bedroom four bath
home in Weston Florida which sold for
almost two million in 2015 and his
mother Vivian currently lives full-time
in a four and a half million dollar two
bedroom three bathroom luxury condo in
Fort Lauderdale it's a lot of property
that's a lot of money he's attacking
Carville you really have to respect this
guy's Grif constantly dressing in normal
clothes on TV to feign relatability
while living like this
masterful con artist it was right under
our nose the whole time
real masterful con artist carlos masa
look I don't want a psychobabble as I
said earlier in the show so I don't want
to speculate as to any unresolved family
issues here that would make him play the
socialist on TV but I want to make a
broader point about the left and about
socialists because we're seeing a big
generational divide here so you got the
old socialist type that's Bernie and you
got the young millennial socialist type
Carlos masa and and there are two kinds
of characters for socialists the ones
motivated primarily by envy and the ones
motivated by self-hatred again I don't
want to get into psychobabble I want to
get into Politico babble and I think you
see these characteristics expressed in
the ideologies themselves so the old
left the old hard and socialist left of
which Bernie is the last remaining
representative I think they are
motivated by Envy that ideology is
motivated by envy it's the rich have too
much we're going to take it from them
you even hear a little bit of this in in
the phrases Carlos mozzie uses eat the
rich right we're gonna that's an old
phrase so they are motivated by taking
material goods from other people they're
motivated by a sort of materialist
Marxist ideology they hate that they
don't have as much money as those other
guys Bernie Sanders the millionaires and
the billionaires are the worst people on
earth we got to take their money then
Bernie becomes a millionaire and all of
us of the millionaires are ok now it's
only the billionaires we got to take
their money but that's what motivates
that ideology Envy for the new left
they're not motivated primarily by envy
what animates that philosophy and
ideology is self-hatred so in the new
left really starting from the 60s and
70s it's no longer about you're rich
we're gonna take your money there's
still traces of that it's really about
we hate our civilization we're so bad
we're awful America has been so evil in
the world white people have been so evil
men have been so evil Western
civilization has been so evil
everything that anything that you can
tidy yourself it's straight people have
been so evil right it's just all about
you
and so you hate that so much that you
you want to get rid of it you see this
espoused in the the millennial
counterparts on the left today it's a
great discomfort with who they are that
men who talk about how terrible men are
straight people who talk about how
terrible straight people are and most
especially those of us who were born and
raised and educated in the West talking
about how Western civilization has
destroyed the world it's pretty pathetic
frankly if you gave me the choice of the
two I would go for the old left at least
it's understandable at least it's a
clearer calculation right you say oh
yeah you have that I want that that's
the oldest impulse in the world but this
self hatred is really sickening and it's
when the sort of cultural
revolutionaries took Marxism from the
realm fury of economics into the realm
of culture that you really started to
see this and the Carlos is the the
latest in a long stream of exponents of
that culture and it's no less pathetic
when it's him and it's no less hilarious
by the way before we content ourselves
that Joe Biden is going to win the
nomination and Trump can eat him for
lunch
in November don't forget there's someone
still lurking in the sidelines there are
a lot of people who said we're not ready
for Joe I don't know if Joe is gonna
make it even the convention I don't know
if he's gonna make it till November
Hillary Clinton is pulling the knives at
again she's not just saying you know
that she still wants to participate
she's not just saying she's not gonna
endorse yet she's also uh apologizing
for what she did in 2016 so you remember
Hillary Clinton put her emails on a
private server so that people couldn't
request those records so that people
couldn't read the corruption that she
regularly engaged in and then when it
became dangerous you know when it when
it looked like people were gonna start
to get into that server she completely
wiped it and then she joked about has
she wiped it on camera and she she had
no explanation for this other than
trying to hide her own crookedness so
back then she said quote as I look back
at it now even though it was allowed I
shouldn't have
used two accounts that was a mistake I'm
sorry about that I take responsibility
that's what Hillary said to ABC News in
September 2015 now she says well that at
the time what she was thinking is we'll
just say what you did was a mistake it
was dumb it's over and that will end it
I wasn't convinced of that but I
understood the frustration of my
campaign so against my better judgment I
said okay fine it turned out to be a
mistake
but because look at all the oxygen it
was sucking out of my campaign but it
didn't end it it didn't end it at all
and it never ended it never ended she's
admitting that she lied when she
apologized this is a bad look for a
politician I think the reason she's
doing it is she's extremely bitter
because the the White House was owed to
her it was that wit that belonged to her
and Trump took that away because it was
supposed to go to Hillary and the
Democrats and then it didn't and she's
really upset about it
it just shows though the duplicity of
the left here I mean Carlos maza right
he's assailing people for wearing street
clothes while they're living in a
mansion and not eating the ridge he's
doing exactly the same thing Hillary
Clinton apologizes and then she admits
so no I didn't really mean my apology I
was just saying it too to get one over
on all you rube deplorable irredeemable
idiot voters right this this race is not
totally over yet there's a lot of room
here for hypocrisy to come out Joe Biden
launches his campaign talking about how
he's gonna bring basically saying he's
gonna bring dignity back to the White
House Joe Biden's got a lot of
corruption but he's gonna have to
account for he's got a lot of drama he's
got a lot of flip-flopping he's got a
lot of hypocrisy that he's going to have
to account for I think the Democrats
today are happy that they dodged a
bullet
Bernie Sanders is almost certainly not
going to be the nominee they've got
their milquetoast choice choice who
doesn't believe anything and wouldn't
even remember if he did believe anything
but this is not over this is only the
beginning
can't wait to see the rest of the show
that
our show today I'm Michael Knowles this
is the Michael Nolt show get your
mailbag questions in see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by Ben
Davies and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy borin
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling technical producer
Austin Stevens assistant director hovel
Woodhouse key editor and associate
producer danny D'Amico audio mixer robin
Fenderson hair and makeup nikka geneva
production assistant ryan love the
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20/20
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]